[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
car test Irvine old is on the road in
the most powerful version of the Porsche
911 the GTS but he's turned the wheel
over to race car driver on comm stuck
this is no ordinary convertible since I
know that's a Porsche 911 GTS over the
decades the GTS has always been a
special car it's not a turbo and not a
gt3 so what it is so special about this
car pancha wacom says it's got a three
liter 6-cylinder engine and it's a twin
turbo with 450 horsepower right now
we're just cruising around with a normal
rate of revs and the engines humming
right along but as soon as he's got some
open road he can engage the turbo and
let rip the acceleration is unbelievable
and to combine all that whether
convertible is fantastic and he can take
it to the racetrack and put the pedal to
the metal
on the track the 911 GTS helps the
driver in a number of respects the
standard fitted PASM electronic damping
control system allows the car to corner
at high speeds and with the Sport Chrono
Package you can measure the speed of
your laps
[Music]
it's a cool gimmick but you don't need
it for cruising around in the
convertible then other qualities come
into play
[Music]
because my note says what matters with
the 911 is not just how it drives but
how it sounds in recent years fans have
been critical
they say that's supposed to be a GTS
turbo so how is this model let's have a
listen
you have the normal exhaust position
haunts you awesome says you don't hear
anything but when you press the exhaust
sound button the Porsche sound system it
really takes off
that's 331 kilowatts the 911 GTS
convertible goes from 0 to 100 in just
4.2 seconds the top speed of our edition
is around 310 kilometers an hour only
the turbo and the Turbo S are faster
where does the performance come from my
note says that every time people sit in
a new 911 they say that it's the best
one ever every time they ask what have
they added now the designers deserve a
compliment says han seokjun if you see
the leaps the model is made from year to
year it's unbelievable where do they get
their inspiration the handling is better
the brakes are better the mileage is
better and the emissions are better and
all that has been combined with better
performance the 911 GTS comes as a coupe
a a.target top Edition and the
convertible we're checking out the
fabric roof opens automatically at the
touch of a button in city traffic to all
the GTS models have a new front section
special seats and central locking wheels
familiar from race car driving
the rear end of the car is 44
millimeters wider than the Carrera S the
black strip between the tinted rear
lights is a particular eye catcher as is
the standard sporty exhaust with the
black tailpipes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the 911 GTS convertible starts at 137
thousand five hundred euros in Germany
[Music]
a segment cars are compacts with an
entry price of around 10000 euros
because of their small size they're
unsuitable for families or trips with
lots of luggage but their agility means
they're great for city driving and for
people who don't have to transport too
many people around
[Music]
Ford used the Fiat 500 as a basis for
their mini segment run about the car but
now Ford has developed a platform of its
own and the resulting model is called
car plus Ford classes it as a sub B
vehicle the lower B segment
[Music]
the exterior of the com+ is a
straightforward affair doing without any
fancy frills the chrome grille is
typically ford at 3.93 meters that com+
is longer than a typical a segment car
[Music]
Sigma Delta Carmen and Ave says it's
immediately apparent that the accomplice
has burst the a segment boundaries as
nearly as long as the seventh generation
Ford Fiesta and the Cobb Plus is
actually taller this also translates
into enhanced comfort in contrast to the
Fiesta Andre has enough room which is
mainly down to the higher roof Andre
says that the trunk clearly positions
the car as a sub beam segment vehicle
less than a B but more than a mini the
cargo space is definitely enough for an
ordinary trip one little niggle when you
open the trunk there's not much to see
you could describe as cleanest as
inexpensive well they have to keep the
price down somehow check on the model we
tested came with the cool and sound
package for a sticker price of eleven
thousand six hundred euros you get a CD
audio system voice control manually
adjustable aircon and an emergency call
assistant it calls for help via a
Bluetooth connected cell phone if the
air bag inflates
[Music]
Andre says that the cob plus puts
pressure on the competition with its
price and size but Ford has also kept
the vehicle in check so that it doesn't
steal customers away from the Fiesta for
example with a relatively small
old-fashioned infotainment display panel
it's being phased out of the eighth
generation Fiesta which will have a
large touchscreen but with the Cobb plus
it's unfortunately the best you can get
the cool and sound comes automatically
with the high performance 1.2 liter
4-cylinder induction engine variant that
has 63 instead of 51 kilowatts and it's
the most powerful cop you can buy
[Music]
Oh Hungary says that in terms of the
engine that keeps a respectful distance
from his big brother the fiestas the car
does not have the latter's 3 cylinder
EcoBoost unit which one an engine of the
Year award there are also no six-speed
manual or automatic gearbox options the
engine in the car plus is adequate but
not much fun to drive the suspension is
above average for the a segment that the
engine loses points but a more tour
Deborah misters Gansett and awesome bits
in ours there are a number of a segment
cars with a lively 3-cylinder turbo
engine despite the amount of hard
plastic the interior of the car plus is
stylish and practical with four drink
holders in between the front seats plus
some extra ones in the back no one's
going to get thirsty
[Music]
the trunk lamp can be turned by pressing
a button next to the light switch or the
key
[Music]
Andre thinks that Ford should have come
up with another designation for the car
plus his segment sub B implies that the
cars been artificially kept below the
Fiesta which is a bit unfair what buyers
get is a more top a segment car at an a
segment price a vehicle that offers more
space and better handling than is
usually the case in the a segment -
forgive me sue
[Music]
an all-wheel drive crossover in Ireland
ideal terrain for the new Suzuki sx4 s
cross to show what it's capable of the
weather here seems to change by the hour
from wind and rain to blue skies our car
reviewer Michelle wants to see whether
the SX 4s cross lives up to Suzuki's
promise to get you where you're going
fast rain or shine
she's testing the version with a 1.4
liter gasoline engine delivering 103
kilowatts of power and a peak torque of
220 Newton meters
it makes the dash to 100 kilometers per
hour and a little over 10 seconds the
manufacturers fuel economy rating is 5.6
liters for 100 kilometers our Edition
has the comfort plus equipment line
prices and Germany started just under 29
thousand euros personally Michelle finds
the engine a little weak and the
steering too soft
she misses that feedback from the
driving surface
among the optional extras is the
all-wheel-drive system all grip last
year's facelift added two new engines to
choose from there's the 1 liter
3-cylinder diesel unit with 82 kilowatts
and the newest and most powerful
gasoline Edition that we're testing the
SX 4s cross does not have permanent
all-wheel drive it's primarily powered
via the front axle if it loses traction
the car switches to both axles this can
take a little more time than expected a
feeling that takes getting used to
but now it's time to unleash all grip as
we go off-road our forest course
provides its fair share of obstacles the
gravel track doesn't seem to really
challenge the sx4 s cross but what about
more slippery conditions the crossover
certainly has the right color for this
adventure at least
[Music]
even deep potholes and seriously muddy
sections are unable to unsettle this car
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the front gives the sx/4 s-cross a broad
and chunky appearance measuring four
point three meters long there's plenty
of space for rear passengers thanks to a
ground clearance of 180 millimeters it
can master regular and bumpy roads with
ease and take on off-road passages
pretty safely even when things get a bit
rocky
Suzuki is definitely fulfilled its
promises Michelle its off-road abilities
mean the SX 4s cross gets you where you
want to go fast on the road or
cross-country
[Music]
the latest generation of the Kia Rio
driving along in Rio and Portugal Lata
goes there have been a range of changes
for the sub compacts fourth edition with
a rework design a new engine and plush
fittings the Korean manufacturer hopes
to score big with buyers in terms of
numbers the Rio is Kia's fourth most
important car in Germany explains
executive stephan cost but the rio is
more than that for its maker it's
generated a lot of new customers who
previously had nothing to do with the
brand
he is unique seven-year warranty could
be among the factors attracting them or
maybe it's the 11,000 690 euro starting
price and the new design line already
been introduced in other models is also
expected to entice newcomers
[Music]
the new design is noticeably stronger
its sporty-er has a wider grille and a
longer hood and a beefy look but they've
also redesigned the interior with
sections clearly divided bold horizontal
lines and the best materials when best
them up the iron the Rios dimensions
have increased slightly the interior
geometry has changed thanks to an
extended wheelbase and shorter overhangs
which also make it more powerful on the
road
[Music]
both front seat and back seat occupants
have ample room
the trunk is also bigger its capacity
has increased from 288 liters to 325
liters and it's able to expand further
and 980 liters the REO comes with a 1.4
liter diesel engine or for gasoline
units including the new 1 liter
3-cylinder turbo version delivering 74
or 88 kilowatts of power there are four
trim levels available and unlike its
predecessors there's a lot to savor even
in the basic model there our driver
assists onboard that you don't usually
see in the small car segment explains
our kia man such as an emergency braking
system with pedestrian detection the
more expensive models feature a sat-nav
and entertainment system which can be
connected to smartphones and a range of
other devices so the new reel has a lot
to offer onboard what our motor journal
is saying about edition 4 it's nice and
quiet both inside and outside the car I
really like that there's a more
economical 3 cylinder turbo onboard it's
more than enough for this model it's
designed very progressively it makes a
solid and appealing impression very
sporty city car very distinct from the
usual monotony it's definitely something
different it's a head turner
the real hasn't gone up in price despite
the significant improvement on the
equipment front we tested the 1-liter
3-cylinder 74 kilowatt engine with a
fuel economy of under five liters per
100 kilometers not just economical but
also agile
[Music]
today we're going for a spin in a
top-selling car from the 1930s the
original Opel cadet the compact sedan
was introduced in 1936 with a selling
price of 2,100 Reichsmarks that made it
a mid-range vehicle in Germany a rare
breed at the time back then Opel was
growing and introducing new models in
the hopes of attracting new groups of
buyers as classy car expert christoph
bauer explains he says that in the mid
1930s Opel was riding a wave of success
in 1935 they became the first German
manufacturer to build over 100,000 cars
per year that made Opel the largest
maker of passenger cars in Europe
however this impressive growth was only
possible thanks to hefty cash injections
from American parent company General
Motors which took a majority stake in
oval in 1929 during the Great Depression
when the German economy started to pick
up the middle class developed and
interesting cars
during this time Opel began using
progressive American production methods
like assembly lines and modular
construction systems in 1935 Opel
started producing Germany's first mass
production car with a monocoque body the
Opel Olympia
[Music]
a slightly more compact version of the
Olympia's body was used to create the
cadet
it's simple technology was largely taken
from opals entry-level model the p4
[Music]
first off says a cadet is a military
trainee who often hopes to become an
officer but is still far from reaching
that goal and he thinks that's an apt
description of the oval cadet while it
had the monocoque body modeled on the
Olympia it lacks some of that much more
expensive cars finesse still at its
premiere in Berlin in 1936 Opel sales
director touted the cadet as an everyday
car for discerning customers and the
cadet was a hit soon the compact model
from rüsselsheim had become the
best-selling car in its class and the
quickest though it eat just 23
horsepower out of its 1.1 litre engine
it still left the competition in the
dust thanks to its low curb weight of
just 757 kilos
[Music]
neither man could do it with a little
patience and a heavy foot Christophe can
almost push the cadet to a hundred
kilometers an hour mark - stop it the
braking system features hydraulic drum
brakes on all four wheels
the base model cadet has two rigid axles
on leaf springs making for a bumpy ride
on country roads however this special
variant has an independent front
suspension it's tuned quite softly
though so when he rounds curves fast the
car really tilts
with my snow christophe says that like
most 30s era vehicles the opel cadet has
that streamlined shape and rounded
aerodynamic design that was so popular
at the time back then integrated
headlights were a real novelty before
that automakers had simply stuck lights
onto the body opals ad executives sang
the praises of the cars design saying
the front end keeps the cabin air tight
while driving and it's smooth rounded
shape makes it easy to clean good to
know
a stylized Zippo and adorns the cadets
hood it was only in the 1950s and 60s
that the airship was gradually replaced
by the lightning bolt logo Opel still
uses today its semaphore type turn
signals instead of blinkers and the
externally mounted spare tire
distinguished the cadet as a pre-war
model
[Music]
the interior is very Spartan with just a
few instruments and a lot of bakelite
like other cars of its day the trunk
space is only accessible from the inside
not very practical
when it came to the engine Opel employed
low-cost tried and true technology
Christos says the engine is a pretty
unspectacular cast-iron model with a 1.1
liters of cubic capacity and 23
horsepower that in powered vehicle since
1931 what's innovative was the cars
monocoque construction in which the body
shell and the undercarriage are melted
to create a single unit this
construction method saved weights making
the car faster and more fuel efficient
that also reduces production costs while
heightening safety because along the way
Opel's engineers had invented the
crumple zone
the crumple zone was a byproduct of the
cars unibody construction though it was
only patented at the end of the 1950's
by Mercedes engineer Bela bovania still
that oversight didn't hurt the cadet the
little Opel found over 30,000 buyers in
its first year alone
[Music]
Christophe says it's progressive
technology soon made that cadet the
best-selling car in its class in Germany
with a market share of 59 percent
ferdinand porsche even used it as a
comparison while developing the VW
beetle germany's first true people's car
in spite of its success the cadet didn't
earn that distinction while it was a
relatively low cost car at the time for
the masses it was still an unaffordable
luxury bus for the paul hop the middle
of overseas that's why over 30 percent
of the production was sold abroad cadets
could be found on the roads in South
Africa Argentina China and New Zealand
after world war ii broke out production
ceased the last original model cadet
rolled off the assembly line in may 1940
[Music]
dans Christophe tells us that while
production of the Opel Olympia resumed
in the post-war years the cadet wasn't
resurrected that's because as part of
the war reparations the entire
production line in rüsselsheim was
confiscated and shipped off to Russia
there the cadet was reborn as the Moscow
vich
400 and remained in production until
1959 thanks to its innovative monocoque
body the oval cadet remained competitive
for many years which Christophe says
qualifies it as a milestone and
automotive history
Ultima babysittin more than 107 thousand
rolled off the assembly line in four
years making the cadet Germany's
best-selling compact car of the pre-war
era in 1962 the model was reintroduced
with a snappy slogan okay like opel
cadet
[Music]
a total of six generations of the cadet
were produced until opal ceased
production in the early 1990s
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]